[Music]
five years ago I thought I lost you
forever
there is no curse that could ever tell
me away from you will you marry me yes
[Music]
have a little bit of news don't ruin my
morning
don't ask me to marry him no I wasn't
really asking nor was I love doesn't
always end well beasty trust me
let us prove you wrong you have done an
admirable job going against your own
nature to raise this child but now he
will finally get the love of a real
mother tonight I consider Elora
my what have you done
Maleficent is a threat to everyone but
you are best at
[Music]
[Applause]
one can never be too careful
[Music]
you
you do not know me
tell me what happened there was another
creature you've spent years caring for a
shoe
now it's time to careful your own fish
fist what habit is a bit of news well on
with it something of any real
consequence and it's certainly no reason
to over react it's just it Prince
Phillip has disappeared no no Phillip
has ghetto fever no wait
leprosy no mrs. Prince Phillip has asked
Aurora it should become his death
ruin my morning
so so
godmother Philip asked me to marry him
poor thing he'll recover my answer was
yes no yes no I wasn't really asking nor
was I what's next I'll turn him into a
goat hmm
I remember the story of a baby a baby
accursed to sleep and never wake up
really who would do such a terrible
thing to an innocent child well there
are many who prey on the innocent I'm
sure your client would agree what do you
mean my kind she means humans there are
fairies missing from the Moors what I'm
missing is some wine
stolen by human poachers that's the
first I've heard of it someone gave the
order
five years ago I thought I lost you
forever
there is no curse that could ever tell
me away from it yes they say that love
can conquer all from curses big to
present to everyone there are many who
prey on the innocent I'm sure your kind
would agree my kind
she means humans start the music but not
every story turns out well
and doesn't know what she's up against
hell for Eva lasting smell
everyone has weakness
oh dear Maleficent mistress of evolve
did PG e-tickets now there is no one in
the world that could play Maleficent
except for Angela Julie seeing her for
the first time back in the black cloak
and warns it's very exciting I'm sure
you're kind but a great maleficents of
character people used to think of is one
thing and now we know more of who she is
do you in this film we posed the
question are we all good are we all bad
what exactly are you implying Angelina
has that aura that's so very kind of you
she's able to bring all of the strength
to Maleficent she's a force of nature my
life says not just dark she's actually
playful she's just otherworldly it takes
your breath away Maleficent is such an
incredible larger-than-life character
hello beastie
I left Lex she's like my alter ego hmm
she's so iconic humans are hilarious
it felt like it was just yesterday in
the first movie I was 14 she's 21 now I
missed you and Sam now and has a little
baby and he's running around the set and
my kids have grown up and they're on the
set we feel like a family I was very
excited to come back to get to be the
three amigos again like we were last
time I love Maleficent she's just very
playful and a little crazy try it with a
little less fine hello she's wild you
have to do a sequel because you believe
you have another chapter of the story
and now we have Aurora as a young woman
and even Maleficent has trouble dealing
with that yes no I wasn't really asking
I love the mother-daughter story and so
Maleficent see of all and Aurora have
this slightly dysfunctional family and
they may be messed up in many many ways
but they have a very honest relationship
it's one of the beautiful things that
makes her family she's asking you to
trust me love doesn't always end well
beastie
[Music]
I don't think Maleficent's bad I think
she's the nicest if I didn't know better
I'd say we're making a threat well do
you do i what no better this idea of her
being evil I think she's actually kind
of playful and and a little crazy what's
next
turn him into a goat hmm possibly
obsessive she's wild I think you're more
effective villain I would have to agree
bad for the bone yeah she will not be
hot doubtful what is so compelling
living vicariously through these
characters through these women that get
to be smart and bad and evil you know
many people fell in love Maleficent
obviously she's not fully evil like
people think she is she's another Disney
Princess she is her her own mind
she wants Aurora to be happy but she's a
little wary of the humans she's
misunderstood pitchforks
humans are hilarious so what she does
she turns out fully you say I'm
different let's go
[Music]
window that is to see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my species
[Music]
[Music]